I'll never be able to experience my
virginity loss my
mom teaching me how to put makeup on you
know my dad teach me how to ride a bike
but I will be able to experience
happiness you know and right now I might
not look like it but I found my
happiness
tonight I just had a look inside myself
z hi Ziggy where were you from
originally where you grow up Arizona I
want to say I was born in Mesa but for
the first three years of my life - I
live in Alabama born in Arizona
no not really my mom is a schizophrenic
so she kind of just checks in and then
checks out yeah
so that's why I littled my dad for the
first two years yeah it's very hard
yeah I mean growing up you don't really
get to speak normal and carry out a
fluid conversation I'm more how to
decide what to say next and choose my
words carefully a lot of times they'll
be under tests
Oh
so I don't like how was your travel with
you described it painful my most
unhappiest time in my life I hated it
how was your dad was he pretty closer to
me about your dad
my dad was a
I'm sorry is hard um dad was a pedophile
so for the whole two years he was just
yeah so like for the first two you
first two years I lived light had a fall
dad and he who saw your so hard I don't
have that many memories of him but the
ones that I do have it is horrible would
molest my me my sister and my brother a
lot and
like torturous
it was oh sorry
so basically my dad had thrown my sister
into a closet and had his way with me
and I was just screaming like screaming
screaming ringing its top of my lungs I
mean I hear my sister's pounding through
the door you're just crappy and then
when it was done he let her out and she
just like came to my side you know
ulcers
the best thing ever and also the worst
thing ever for us go kind of just like
send us a card you know
it was like the best thing and the worst
thing it bonded us but it also set us
apart
because you so fast your sister
no she uh having a schizophrenic mom
really put his toll on us my sister
can't have any relationships rather be
family or friends my brother I think he
is starting to be schizophrenic and my
youngest brother is not talking to
anybody he had to live my mom by himself
for four years and it's just he never
talked about it she won't talk to us
he's angry he's just angry
yeah yeah uh they're still married to
this day my mother is still trying to
get in contact with my dad she thinks
that I don't know what she thinks she
calls me sometimes and says she's sorry
and then she calls me other months and
says she doesn't know what's going on
most as I'm she was leaving of Who I am
she just calls me she's weird
so with my dad for two years and then
CPS threatened to take us away because I
rather not say but anyways so my mom
came in all the way to Alabama and then
brought us to her house but my mom is a
crackhead and a schizophrenic and the
prostitute and just like the worst
person ever so when we lived with my mom
just stuck in this room and it was just
one Matt like a bed with no sheets no
pillows no clothes I didn't have any
food I mean when I would go to school
that would be the only time I would eat
and then over the weekend I would have
nothing and my mom would go out on
benders most of time she wouldn't be
home for like three weeks at a time so I
mean it was really hard she's really
hard
I would always lie school saying that I
was just a disobedient kid I refused to
do my laundry she used to do anything
like took shower and though my mom never
taught me how to take a shower and it
was really bad I mean it was really bad
I was horrible I should always have like
a revolving door of boyfriends
yeah those boyfriends I was 11
CPS took us out of my mom's house into
my grandparents house I could I'm most
disabled oh so it was really hard
she had a scooter and it turns out
that's where most of the abuse came from
was from my grandmother so it didn't do
any good taking us out of this one I'm
putting us there because it just it was
hard I mean we couldn't take showers we
had no money for food we had everywhere
I would go I would pick up pennies
everywhere I would go and every would
always make fun of me I mean it was so
sad like I I don't even I don't remember
when my grandma bought me new clothes
would always go to the goodwill get like
50 cent shorts that were too small was
she not happy we live in a one-bedroom
trailer in Arizona with me my brother
brother my sister grandpa
sometimes my mom my aunt and my uncle so
to be like eight and then their kids to
be like eleven people sometimes in a
one-bedroom trailer in Arizona was no
water heater and it was horrible I had
uncle or addicts heroin addicts my
grandma is addicted to prescription
pills and my grandfather it's not really
my grandfather is an alcoholic
yeah you know when I was 13 I started
running away from my grandparents home
those were some fun days the crazy of
fun I got tricked a lot as a result of
not having a home and running away I got
mixed up in like some gang members and I
was crazy they just I don't know how to
feel about this one they told me that
they would protect me in a way and I
would be family but I had to have sex
with all the gang members so I had this
mr. truck that I would have these guys
come in and out sometimes two at a time
and then
at the end of it they told me that I was
trash and that it wasn't gonna happen
and that they just used me and I just
kind of felt numb at that point you know
because after it happened with my dad
and everything else in my life it just
toners walked away yeah I literally
walked away and slept on the streets for
a few nights
felony like this one girl she's really
nice to me she's so nice and I feel bad
those I had slept with her brother
I slept her third cousin and their
cousins uncle it was all mess growing up
like being molested running up I thought
that that's what people wanted you know
they wanted the inside of me not me
so I would go out and give myself away
just for a place to stay sometimes does
that make sense I mean so bad all right
thirteen this one guy told me to go take
care of this guy and I I did everything
it was gross I did everything for $20
$20 I mean can you imagine doing all
that for $20 I'm so nervous
what did you unless I'm stepping over
something
[Music]
so I kept running away from my
grandparents they were neglected and
didn't really care about me I ended up
getting like an STD and tricked into
gangs and stuff so my grandparent and I
came home with this tattoo at twelve
thirteen I want to say my thirteen I
came home to talk to all my
grandmother's that she had enough of me
and signed me away to CPS it was
horrible
I mean it was just like a year three
months and juvenile detention and then
eight months was that eight to nine
months and rehabilitation centers
lelee lockdown no shoes no freedom can't
even look out a window
I mean that was like one of the worst
times in my life
Oh overly well I'm trying so hard not to
cry I'm so sorry
my own grandmother could have taken me
home and put me on ankle bracelet and
she about for me to go to a lock-up
facility in rehab and no one called me
none of my siblings even knew where I
was that my grandmother put me in rehab
so she could keep receiving me so she
was carry money so after we have I got
out I end up going to a group home and
they only kept me for a month and then I
went to a I'm sure it was called but
it's one of those foster homes where you
can't be let out of sight and they have
such watching you at this point I was on
like eight different prescription drugs
I had like eight doctors tell me I was
severely bipolar and I could be
schizophrenic and
it just scared me are you gonna oh so
hard so I ended up going group home
I'm sorry juvie group home group home
foster home another foster home and then
another foster home and I'm back to a
group home when I aged out of the room
from that eighteen and when I when I
decided to get out 18 I started to be
myself off with these prescription drugs
it was hard
ooh so hard I had like spotty moments in
my brain and I just my emotions were up
and down I so bad but it's better now
it's a lot better now now I feel like
it'd be me you know I have went through
so much in life
but doesn't mean I have to keep going
through that I just I don't know like
all these bad times lead up to the good
person that I am 25
how to cut everybody out of my life to
be able to focus on myself and know that
none of that stuff was my fault
no but it was my bravery that you know
getting us out of there cuz I guess like
the hole CPS thing that I don't want to
talk about I guess my aunt I was telling
me that when I was a little girl I
walked up to her and I told her that my
dad touching me here do you touch your
kids here you know so I guess even has a
little tool kit I knew no you know but
[__] happens do you survive
good
no I guess I'm still surviving it in a
way because it never really goes away
you know but it does get easier over
time my 14th birthday my grandmother
admitted me into the psychiatric ward
thinking I was crazy and that I should
not celebrate my birthday and I don't
know I felt really bad for myself but I
saw others that needed more sympathy
than me you know more help and that kind
of at that moment I started changing my
thinking stop doing all pity for
yourself [__] happens
well I was dancing in Arizona
yes I was at cheetahs and the bouncer
that I knew told me that he'd need some
porn people so I told him as a bet yeah
I bet you do if you can find me an agent
I'll go hide in the start literally 24
hours later I'm on a plane to California
so it kind of just and my life was
shitty in Arizona I was ready to go I
was so ready I was not even the best I'm
not doing about I live in a hotel room
barely scraping by
I'm like trying to pay for my court
classes oh gosh it's really bad so don't
worry about being awesome
five happiest five years of my life I
feel like I got to lose my virginity
in a way my anal virginity it was pretty
nice yeah it was I was proud of that day
and
it's been a good experience for you yeah
I mean you have those people like in the
[__] they have drug addicts on one
side crazy people with other abusers
users but that's where you gotta get him
refit in I mean self-will and being able
to say no I won't do that for money or
no I know where I stand it's very
beneficial or yes I will do that so the
first time I did it on camera was in
Arizona actually before I started to get
into the agency
it was bathroom casting couch um that's
actually why I made the bet with my
bouncer because I told my just done
bathroom it I don't really consider
backroom porn since is it is very very
very amateur in your first time even
though it is having sex on camera but it
was really nice his name was Eric and it
was the first time made it anal as well
on that day but it was my choosing you
know and my choice to go on camera it it
was empowering I don't know they're just
kind of it felt like it gave me the
power back not just cuz of course I like
to have sex but
because it let me choose that make sense
it still lets me choose like I mean a
lot of people won't like that I don't do
transgender or bisexual stuff but
my choice its power enough important the
porn industry has changed right oh yes
they've gone way left as the gay left I
mean I mean they're just crazy I mean
there's guys dressing up and putting
fake boobs and ourselves and I mean to
each his own but I don't push you know I
mean quadruple anal and all that crazy
stuff I mean I love my butthole I would
never do that to my butthole I've done
this triple penetration so to in the
vagina and one of the butt which is also
one in the mouth
this is quadruple penetration
technically
and a gangbang I don't really I mean did
I really count though because no I
didn't want gang members back in the day
that one time but this is more of just
like my choice so I mean let's go with
this one
horns better so how much of your
childhood experiences do you think let
you do this I think all of them led me
down this path I really needed to go
down this path to be able to be
comfortable myself sexually and mentally
as well as emotionally my self defense
mechanism was to be angry I used to be
act like I was the toughest person in
the world I mean I was so angry all the
time I would fight everybody but now I'm
just happy I'm so tired of being angry
it's the taste of takes it on your soul
you know just poison
yeah it is
thank you for having me